all right janet janet uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i grew up in south central yeah in
the real
hardcore south central i'm getting
affiliated
and um i started games when i was like
13 years old how was your
childhood yet both your parents my step
direct me yeah
yeah my stepdad raped me and my mom my
mom still with him for the to the last
day he died
when it was last year he raped me and my
sister so
when that happened i took it upon myself
to to think that um
that i was just like i used to tell my
mom
myself i used to do something she never
believed me or my sister
so my sister left one day my my oldest
my one
one of my my sisters he was rapping too
so what he what happened was that um in
the process of all this happening
my sister left me and she she left when
my auntie and left me in the house
with the problem so um um
that kind of [ __ ] me up you know it's
even worse
because now she's out of the picture
being raped and
so now it's me so now now i'm getting
more often than i
was getting it now from my stepdad and
um
it was this it was it was [ __ ] up it
was really bad
yeah this went on for a long time oh
yeah come on that's happened when i was
seven years old
like six seven and i'm i'm what 40 now
but he just died last year so
this happened to like i was like this
happened six
like three years seven like for two a
year i said a year two years
yeah yeah he raped me and stuff and me
and my sister and um
i remember being um this old i've been
being like
when i was like 17 and she was like
eight like around 19
we told my our mom and she didn't
believe us she said
you guys are crazy you guys use drugs we
were like at that age mom come on now we
don't
so my sister passed away last year and
um i don't have religion i don't i don't
have i'm not
in the street by myself you know i go to
i went to present the 12 years in
upstate
churchilla and um i'm just i just know
nothing but the hardcore life out there
the dangerous life gangs drugs guns and
gang bangers and
you know fighting in you know i just i
mean
i mean i have a long face shooting for
you know what were you in prison for
um first time i'll be dead with a
kitchen knife stabbing somebody in the
kitchen yeah probably daddy the father
might say my child
oh you're yes i did i'm seven years of
state
yes and uh
prostitution started for you at what age
um
i was like 13 14 14 yes
when i ran away from my house yes do you
remember your first time
um yes i said in hollywood right there
my first ticket too
you got a ticket too um dressed i think
they call it um
um not trespassing um i forgot
there you go that one yes yeah and um
they let me go the first time but the
second time it was like i went to jail
to twin towers this was when twin tower
was open so i'm like
wait wait wait wait we talked about way
back to where i could
i could uh um the for that you know that
lawsuit that they got going on right now
and stuff
about the women that whoever got was to
jail in 2000 whatever
i qualified for that so yeah i used to
go to train i went to
trade towers and stuff for impressive
[ __ ] and stuff and um
you know when they all had a bad
experience to wear like my friend um we
were in the street
over there in long beach and um wow man
it was just bad
she i guess she didn't know what she she
she just never list she didn't listen
she didn't i told her exactly what to do
but she went the wrong way and she got
killed yeah she got killed
right there and then and she got she got
raped they raped her first and then they
killed her
yes yes hispanic people yes
stuff that i didn't know that she was
doing you know what i mean because uh
before i used to be like oh they really
pray as my friend
i want to help everybody i want to help
everybody everybody
and it's now it's it's like you cannot
help know somebody they don't want to
help themselves you know
so i just got out of jail again um two
years ago and um
they gave me two years i did a year and
due to this
kobe 19 they gave me five months early
kickout
and i came home and i lost i lost my
kids i lost my house i lost everything
i'm in the streets right now
yep i'm just right now i'm in the
streets yes i'm homeless oh yeah i'm
homeless
i sleep in i sleep in in my car so
friends that i know you know what i mean
they let me shower sometimes in the
house
i mean you know does it go without
showering sometimes i mean sometimes the
position the police put me over it like
you homeless i'm like i'm homeless like
no you're not homeless
you're not homeless i'm like oh my god
really like i am homeless like
yes i'm homeless what does homies look
like you know
so you know like yesterday was
thanksgiving it was familiar it was like
any other day
any other day yeah because i don't i
lost my son too
he's gay member too he's doing 50 to
live so
you know it's kind of hard when you when
i
sometimes i say i want to change but
then it's like for what
and it's like i waited out you know
but i think i like this i i that's one
thing i know is this lifestyle
you think you're addicted to it yeah
they're using drugs as well yes what do
you use
math that helps you do this kind of work
right
yeah it knows my pain
[Music]
do you talk to your family at all not at
all
i don't
and where are your kids in the system
social services
yeah they took them away from me because
i'm only had nobody um
to pick them up when the police pulled
me over you know what i mean so
i was doing so so good i asked myself
i told a guy like why would you lay all
this happen to me
when i was just doing fine with my kids
like
because i don't want to change i do but
it's like
i don't know
do you get depressed sometimes oh yeah
okay
i um yes that triggers that it
triggering
and then it's i mean i don't have no
support i mean
you know how you always have somebody to
push you like come on come on come on
like
somebody you know i don't have that you
know what i mean i mean all the people
i i'm around with they do the same [ __ ]
i do so it's like
i mean why would they care for me when
they lost their kids already
so it's like you know the streets is
rough out there right now
what happens what helps you survive is
there's you tell yourself this is just
something
you need to do just to pay the bills or
it bills yeah
yes but being molested as a kid did that
kind of
yeah lead you down this path yeah you
feel like maybe if that hadn't happened
well maybe my mom would pay my attention
to us you know
so
i feel that all my family
discombobulated because they always talk
about me
being drugs and gangs in prison and um
you know just just things that you know
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
if i would have made better choices i
wouldn't be where i'm at right now
because i can't blame other people for
what i do
it's me and um i'm looking
um i see live i i see like
um like people that are in the streets
always got something to blame like oh
cause i'm like this because i know
it's because it's cuz it's you you know
i mean like
i joined the gang when i was 13 so
because i thought the world was gonna
end
you know so
i don't know have you done that before
in love yeah like two times but
i don't know like um i don't i don't
really care like
when i'm on the street i'm so more like
to do vicious stuff than to be
sexually you know me because um i'm like
uh
well aggressive like
like um don't i don't like nobody tell
me what to do
you know i mean like um
like um i feel like i have to go hard
hard on people you know i mean and um
i don't care if i scare them i don't
care if
i fight i like to i just fought somebody
two days ago i mean
that's just my thing that's i black out
when i you know i take segments too so
i don't know i'm just i don't know
he has a lot to do but being in the
streets and then my son my mom
it's just a lot a lot of stuff that
bills me my sister passed away
and then you have my other phone boy
from my neighborhood that pastor got
killed
they went inside look you know his rv
shot him
so he's like like man
just a lot of stuff and you know i don't
want to end up like
like these people like lost lost like a
lost soul
i don't i don't want to end up like that
what's your biggest regret being from a
game
game yeah
it's not worth it
yeah because when you you're a gang
member you fee you
you you you affiliate you you that's
what you
um notice that's what you're known for
you know i mean the police pull me over
if
if i'm if i'm with you right now coming
from restaurants eating police pull me
over
they're gonna see my chest with them
like oh yeah what what are you
what is this guy doing with this girl
like this you know like they judge us
they they do you know they booked they
they judge the cup that worked by his
cover you know
my family is like that you know that's
why my family is always combabilated
because they always
always nothing nice to tell me it's
always bad it's always bad it's always
bad
so i just say [ __ ] my family too
you know it'd been three years even
from the day i got arrested in november
of last year
um i haven't talked to my family for
three [ __ ] years and when i got
arrested i called my mom after three
years and she
this is the first the thing she told me
why are you calling cause you're in jail
you need me now you need me huh huh she
said oh because there he met his panic
oh wow and then and i was like oh man i
was so mad
mad they said they were not going to
pick up my kids
they left my kids in the system so i
mean you know
i do myself i do everything on my own i
asked my homeboys my friends
you know they've been looking out for me
so sometimes i could go to sleep without
eating you know because i don't have
money to eat
street life is just ruthless isn't it it
is that's why i tell people
if you go home if you have home go home
like go home to your mom
go home to your kids like don't [ __ ]
that up you know what i mean like
because
it's not worth it like don't [ __ ] that
up be smart you know
what was the best time of your life hi
my baby my last one c-section
and what was the worst time knowing that
my son
um is doing 50 alive
if you could change something about your
life
your childhood what would you change
to become a better mother for my kids
i feel voiceless sometimes but i don't
let nobody know that
because i'm in the street
all right janet thank you so much for
talking with me
thank you
you